12 de octubre de 1492 el navegador
italiano Cristóbal Colón llega a América
en una misión para la corona española
ese día la historia cambió para siempre
se empieza entonces a hablar de
descubrimiento de América un hallazgo
desmentido por la llegada de otras
expediciones previas y por los múltiples
pueblos originarios que ya habitaban
530 años después el debate no ha
terminado es el 12 de octubre el día de
la raza y de la hispanidad como se le ha
nombrado tradicionalmente o mejor
cambiarle el nombre a día del encuentro
Entre dos mundos como se le llaman chile
el día de la nación pluricultural en
México el día de la de colonización en
Bolivia O como le llaman también en
Estados Unidos desde el año pasado el
día de los pueblos indígenas
pero Estados Unidos todavía celebra
simultáneamente el Día de la Raza
nomenclatura contra la que desde los
años 60 y hasta la actualidad los
movimientos indígenas hacen activismo
para reescribir la historia en la línea
en los últimos años se han derribado y
vandalizado múltiples estatuas de
colonizadores así fue en Colombia
[Aplausos]
Puerto Rico
y hasta en Miami
para el de colonialismo la
reivindicaciones cuestionan la
imposición occidental y colonial que ha
vivido América por siglos lo califican
de genocidio por los millones de
indígenas asesinados
mientras que los más puristas consideran
que es un golpe a la memoria histórica y
creen que celebrar la hispanidad es
también celebrar una identidad